who's starting this bad boy all right
I'm grandma
are we playing on the Hawaii level dead
games just about killing granny going
that gun task kill your grandmother oh
goodness me listen okay come down here
to bits play this map what's the button
to take these eggs I get out of here
without a key thank you man just find
the kitchen
yeah it's Halloween let's break some
Halloween cookies for my lovely
grandchild there's two of you I need
some sugar yeah yeah I got you granny
both my parents were pole vaulters
please I can't quite grab them granny I
can't quite make it up this counter
grant there we go I'm up oh hey that's
not very nice okay just hey make cookies
don't don't aim that don't don't point
me oh yes check that small child present
for you
you're not my grandson can you interact
with me I don't know I can't seem to do
anything
keep coming into my house throwing
bottles at me hey there's a key I've got
the eggs oh good gracious I'm not tall
enough for this countertops seem to be a
chin height some tools
I threw it down on here right here wait
wait what are you doing in the garage
nothing the garage is no place for
playing drama
it's okay oh my goodness I can't no hey
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
my crotch is on fire
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
my mouth take some of your pills I found
our third scene stay back I found your
pills I just found
I know where my to get freaky go outside
though no you stay in there you stay in
there okay you stay with your friend
don't come out here
Oh Oh No Oh something bad Oh to the door
no grandma your pill I took my
oh my god don't kill me I'm health left
I will not kill you grandma
yeah well that is that's true true
family right there that's love
appreciate your consideration oh there's
a basement
oh you don't go in the basement that's
what granny keeps her dildos swing it's
not that kind of swing all of these
boxes are you stuck in the door no no no
I'm here alright don't open too many
things ready I found another pill last
one really didn't I did not want that is
this a bug
young man yes young man found this get
watch out running man back down the
stairs backwards oh my god how does
granny win granny I told you Jesus
granny next has to do a voice cuz that
[ __ ] hurts oh well at least I get to
move now granny moves so slow I can't
remember what I have to do I need my
dementia my god men Chappell's alright
have I wanted my last day I was so slow
these old bones
I'm glad I just leave all my clothes
around oh I've been beaten by a door
granny that's not even a thriving mess
alright why would my grandchildren try
the Ruby well we were supposed to go to
the park today what instead you weren't
such a [ __ ] I don't have a watering can
but I'm my dick grandma language made me
fall granny has to water hey what's up
[Applause]
granny what's this by the TV clip the
clip this and put it son brother why
would you do that cuz you didn't take us
to the park park it's beautiful out here
go enjoy the Sun your bad grandma you're
a [ __ ] grandson so even Stephens your
know how to make I've been through two
world wars
I think I can curse a little bit where
the hell hunter back back baby brother
it's not helpful because I don't know
what
way that is not open garage sign I love
the sunshine do you know how long it's
gonna take granny - I'm playing
pacifists so don't make promises you
can't keep
where the hell are you do you out the
front door brother you old piece a [ __ ]
door we're still Grady's walking in the
back door Beckett black and interest
front front door back door [ __ ]
whatever these goddamn meteors keep
coming miss me [ __ ] happen freakin nope
wrong pills anybody seen my green fields
yes I told you what the ones in the bush
you didn't grab granny where they agreed
granny always helps
you're my favorite grandson hello
try missed me by that much oh there's my
pills bottle of water
yeah that's not that's not gonna be good
my heart medication down how many pills
does grandma knee I thought you had left
than that oh it's only up in the top
right of your screen
35 last I looked what did Bob do to you
throw a knife at a foot well we'll never
know what happens when granny wins we'll
never know reclose I think so there was
only two pills left
I guess I'm granny then yeah you're
granny I cut the power now this whole my
god I'm the strike hey Mark yeah what's
up oh wow I unlocked it last round what
did you do I don't know at the end of
the round it was just like hey you
unlocked the ninja skin Oh we're able to
move now I thought we were still were
playing and it's so dark yeah what's up
hey I was going for that key I got the
key ninja costume nerd I remember a time
back when I didn't have to tease my
grandson's to get them to behave
grandma yes I'm hungry well die of
starvation you little [ __ ] okay you're
being overly austell we have done
nothing to you go in the kitchen and
make us some food I hate all of you
all right well the kitchen yet or what
what are you doing I'm going as fast as
I can
the stairs aren't kind to me what is
going
in here oh you have a lantern that's
that's not good
granny I love you all I want to do is
show you my love grandma grandma give me
a hug hug me grandma please
just love me I don't I won't want well I
would imply I have a heart and I just
don't hey grandma you want to try and
spray me some more I don't have anything
with which to spray I've dried up in my
old age that's really gross grandma
that's called that's different really
girls oh I can't do either one now can I
just say say you care about me and I
won't throw this knife at you just say
you must not tell lies say say you care
about what's my name
grandma what's my name just say my name
grandson take this oh it's dark out oh
good ninja Sun my least favorite of my
two children grandchildren well I wish
we'd never had you because they're in
ninja but here you are only spawns of
Satan did my mom like that you make make
me yeah
does the baby dab every time it jumps
yes ninja grandson come upstairs know
where it is grandma you think I'm an
idiot and this is why no one loves you
why do you think you're alone huh why do
you go this was a trick it was a trick
of all time it was a trail for it that's
why you're the idiot grandson grandma
I'll come upstairs and you are not gonna
kick me okay fine I'll kick you we're
gonna talk about this grandma and mom
could talk oh I could talk for days you
were going to tell you about the Cold
War yeah go ahead
it was like that only worse Rama you
promised you promised grandma I haven't
had my pillows I forgot oh that's sad
and horrible yeah but also it's my
objective there's a flaming oh god I've
not felt this penetrate me since
grandfather was still alive this was on
fire like this - where is grandma can't
hit me back here I'm gonna try that's
what you get
Oh grandma's in a lot of pain now don't
don't don't
there's your green pills if you want
them you can at me use I don't need
those pills I need the other ones right
now which one's the non green ones why
oh they just make me feel a little more
full of life and ready to get down and
bang oh my god oh god grandma it's time
for you to say good night
no not image weird give grandma [ __ ]
second here no you are invincible
nothing it's oh come on why is your aim
so good
[Music]
just give granny a [ __ ] moment to go
to the garage and all the lights Becca
no grandma no I can't get back how's it
feel to be on the floor like us oh this
reminds me of the first time I met your
grandfather are you doing grandma
grandma broke and quite like all
grandmas broken isn't she everybody
right God well that's not the part we
want to ride hang on even death will be
very jealous you fourth son tween legs
part please just it's time for bond oh
great he's blasting off again I don't
think it's gonna happen from three from
the bottom I'll do it from the top um
yeah bottom pulled on ready lined up on
target three two one go what still oh my
got stuck in the wall oh you're
resilient I actually did I win yes you
are grandma
yeah you wanted good
[Music]